طوال فترة الإدارة الرابحة ، كانت
العلاقات بين الصين والصين
في مأزق ، تم انتخاب الرئيس ترامب
في عام 2016
بعد حملة ضد الصين متهمة
إياها
بالتلاعب بعملتها في السوق العالمية ،
لا يمكننا الاستمرار في السماح
للصين باغتصاب بلدنا وهذا ما
يفعلونه '  أثناء سنواته الأولى في
المنصب ،
احتفل ترامب أيضًا بعلاقاته الشخصية الوثيقة
مع الزعيم الصيني شي جينبينغ ، كان لدينا
أجمل
قطعة من كعكة الشوكولاتة التي رأيتها على الإطلاق
وكان
الرئيس شي يستمتع بها ولكن بحلول
الأشهر الأخيرة من رئاسته ترامب
لقد ألقى باللوم علنًا على
الصين في الوباء المميت الذي ينتشر في
جميع أنحاء الولايات
المتحدة والعالم ، فقد كان خطأ
الصين وستدفع الصين ثمناً باهظاً
ما فعلته لهذا البلد
ستدفع الصين ثمناً باهظاً
ما فعلته  بالنسبة للعالم ،
شهدت السنوات الأربع الماضية المضطربة
حروبًا تجارية ، عضلات عسكرية تستعرض
إغلاق القنصليات بالمثل ،
ومحاولة
فرض حظر على الشركات الصينية.  تطبيق al media tick
tock
الذي دفع بعض المسؤولين الصينيين للحديث
عن حرب باردة جديدة
في الأشهر العديدة الماضية كانت العلاقة
بين أكبر اقتصادين في العالم
أيامًا سامة بعد أن أعلن جو بايدن
فوزه في الانتخابات الرئاسية.
لاحظنا أن السيد
بايدن قد أعلن عن انتخابه بنجاح ،
ونحن نتفهم أن نتيجة
الانتخابات العامة سيتم تحديدها
وفقًا لقوانين
وإجراءات الولايات المتحدة.
وجهاً لوجه مع الحادي عشر ، لكن بصفتي
مرشحًا
رئاسيًا ، تبنى بايدن خطًا متشددًا ، فإن ما كنت سأفعله في
الصين هو اللعب وفقًا للقواعد الدولية ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى أن نجعل بقية
أصدقائنا معنا
يقولون للصين إن هذه هي القواعد التي
تتبعها  لهم أو أنك ستدفع
ثمن عدم دفعها
اقتصاديًا وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية
تحذر من أن العلاقات من
غير المرجح أن تفعل ذلك  تحسن في عهد الرئيس
بايدن معترفًا بأن الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين
يتشاركون الشك في الصين ، لكن
العصر العالمي الذي تديره الدولة يشير
أيضًا إلى أنه من المتوقع أن يعين بايدن
المزيد من المسؤولين المحترفين في
فريقه الدبلوماسي
، وبالتالي سيكون من الممكن بالنسبة لنا التوترات الصينية
أن تستغرق وقتًا قصيرًا  يقول الخبير الصيني
ويلي لامب إن
المسؤولين الصينيين قلقون من نهج بايدن
متعدد
الأطراف للدبلوماسية ، كما أنهم قلقون للغاية
بشأن حقيقة أن بايدن سيكون أكثر
كفاءة
ونجاحًا في تشكيل جبهة موحدة ضد
الصين من خلال العمل مع
حلفاء أمريكا التقليديين في أوروبا.  وآسيا
على الأقل قد يؤدي بايدن إلى إحداث
تغيير في
لهجة هذا التنافس المحتدم بين هاتين
الدولتين
إيفان واتسون cnn hong kong